[Applause]
[Music]
on the 11th April 2015 a historic
meeting took place between raúl Castro
the president of Cuba and Barack Obama
it was celebrated in Panama and landing
was the first bilateral meeting of the
US and Cuban presidents in 50 years four
months earlier both leaders announced
they would remake relations between the
two governments today the United States
of America is changing its relationships
with the people of Cuba and as they said
they would do so was done in just a
short period of time that he first
changes were made in relations between
both countries started to return to
normal
now I don't seem like we see this a lot
on this channel but the arrival of
Donald Trump the White House well it
changed everything again the new
President of the United States has
ordered that the u.s. steps back from
most of the changes that Obama initiated
with Cuba so the question might be why
is he doing this what does he expect and
what are the consequences of this new
policy we're going to look at all of
these questions in this video but before
we do let's have a quick look at the
history of the relations between these
two countries
[Music]
the embargo
after the so-called Cuban Revolution
took place against Batista's
dictatorship the new government and the
islands led by Fidel Castro soon started
to nationalize every kind of capital
good and company land hotel factories
well everything was up for grabs by the
government so the Cuban Revolution ended
on the 1st of January 1959 and already
volume a the government had begun huge
expropriations all across the country
now our and he might probably be able to
imagine this is something that the US
did not really take very well there were
thousands of lawsuits filed in the US
which had close relations with Cuba at
the time further if this wasn't enough
to upset the US the Soviet Union was
already getting on well with Fidel
Castro who's at this moment when as a
penalty Washington passed the first
trade embargo against the island an
embargo that slowly grew stronger as the
relations between these countries were
getting worse in fact after the Missile
Crisis of 1962 at Kennedy even limited
US travel to Cuba since then lands with
the exception of short periods of better
relations under the governments of
foreign Carter's various governments
over the United States have kept to the
embargo and the policy of isolating Cuba
economically in place
Ronald Reagan labeled the island as a
sponsor of terrorism and later Bill
Clinton made even more severe
restrictions and the embargo was put
into law since then traveling to Cuba
and investing in Cuba or doing business
with the Cuban government has been very
limited for Americans well that is until
Barack Obama came to office in February
2008 Fidel past power to his brother
Raul Castro that same year elections
took place and Obama said it was time to
use a different approach with Cuba it
was time to improve diplomatic relations
between the two countries
Obama didn't want to wait and shortly
after he arrived in the White House he
softened some of the restrictions that
were in place on Cuba for example he
allowed Cubans in the u.s. to send money
to the island and he started to allow US
citizens to travel to Cuba many more
things followed these first gestures
during the years Obama was in office
many restrictions against Cuba were
reduced and in December of that year Rao
Castro and Obama met in Panama
significant progress was being made but
I think what we have both concluded is
that we can disagree with a spirit of
respect and civility and that over time
it is possible for us to turn the page
and develop a new relationship between
our two countries and that is how to
great moments took place in 2015 the
embassies reopened in both countries and
in March of 2016 Air Force one landed in
Havana for the first time in history
[Music]
Seba hadn't posted a sitting American
president since 1928 a policy of
isolation designed for the Cold War made
little sense in the 21st century
the embargo was only hurting the Cuban
people instead of helping it's time to
let the embargo it is time now for us to
leave the past behind it is time for us
to look forward to the future together
Roberto de esperanza of all these new
policies towards Cuba with taking over
and even though the embargo and laws
were technically still enforced the
Obama administration managed to find
legal loopholes to allow the relations
between these two countries to be
something close to normal when Ivana
left the White House Americans could
travel freely to Cuba immigrants could
send unlimited money back to the country
American companies could invest in Cuba
and even planes of American companies
frequently landed at Jose Marti
International Airport the new
relationship well it was working but
then Donald Trump's became President of
the United States and as we already
mentioned everything changed
[Music]
Trump and Cuba on the 16th of June 2017
Trump decided to take this new policy
back and he did so in a neighborhood of
Miami called Little Havana effective
immediately I am canceling the last
administration's completely one-sided
deal with Cuba as soon as he finished
his speech Trump signed guidelines for
his so-called
new policy with Cuba after a 50 year
embargo with the country it could hardly
be described as actually being new
Trump will completely reverse Obama's
policies many will be maintained for
example the opening of embassies and
commercial flights between the two
countries however from now on trips of
Americans to Cuba will be limited as
they won't be able to go individually
and any relationship with diesem they
holding group directed by the
governments which controls more than 50%
of the Cuban economy will be forbidden
but don't think that Trump has always
had this hardline attitude towards Cuba
quite the opposite in fact in 1998 he
tried to build a hotel on the island
contradicting the embargo and at the
beginning of 2016
he supported Obama's new policies
towards the country but here a visual
politic we think that Trump's attitude
towards Cuba well it could be a mistake
so let's have a look at exactly why
[Music]
[Applause]
Trump's mistake
let's make one thing really clear right
now the embargo against Cuba has been a
total failure the US embargo which is
blocked all trade and investment with
Cuba for the past 55 years has not
worked this failed to isolate the Cuban
government failed to regain any
nationalized property and succeeded in
giving an excuse to the Castro
government for its abuses and economic
mismanagement for more than 50 years the
embargo has been completely useless it
hasn't accomplished anything and on top
of that of the Cuban government has used
it as an excuse to justify their poor
economic situation but wait just a
second it because this is not the end of
it not even close reversing Obama's
policies is a mistake for several
reasons importantly improved relations
with the US have meant better security
for the United States Obama signed
several important cooperation agreements
and since 2015
given authorities have given information
on drug and human trafficking to the US
and on the other hand Russia and China
have also set their eyes on the island
again russia says it may reopen Soviet
error military bases in Cuba
you can probably imagine what a blow the
national security of the United States
this would be this is why making
relations more difficult means nothing
more than forcing the Cuban government
you seek better relations with Moscow or
Beijing not exactly a brilliant option
for the US and there is so much more
Trump new policy will only damage the
interests of many American companies as
well as put at risk see major changes
that are taking place on the island
how is Cuba changing since raúl Castro
came to power he has admitted that Cuba
needs a change of directions and that
the Cuban model simply is not working
some people are saying that he wants to
emulate China be open to the world thus
maintain control the truth is that up
until now changes have been scarce and
slow but even so these changes could be
self and now the Venezuela can no longer
help the islands these changes have
become more and more urgent so now let's
have a look at what's been happening
since 2011 when reforms took place and
freelance entrepreneurship was made a
lot easier since 2011 the number of
self-employed workers in Cuba is four
times larger and today the number
exceeds half a million workers the
government is also allowed private
farming for small farmers and
restaurants and small tourism businesses
are growing and spreading across the
country the vault is open this wealth it
certainly helps this process for example
almost all private businesses in Cuba
are working off money coming in from
abroad a B&B already has 22,000
apartments homes or rooms available in
Cuba further we shouldn't forget about
less tangible things like the exchange
of ideas mutual knowledge and the
strengthening of the private sector
every dollar left in the hands of cab
drivers hotel workers waitresses and
valets is a show of what awaits Cubans
if they reject socialism US Senator Rand
Paul take a look at China and compare
the country as it is today to the
country it was during Mao's time since
the country opened itself up to the
world hundreds of millions of people
have left poverty behind yes China like
Cuba it's still a terrible dictatorship
but thanks to their open policy the
chine
these house today more freedom and a
better standard of living than they've
ever had before the short of the matter
is that the embargo policy well it
failed and Trump's insistence in going
back to it is not going to achieve
anything that the weakening of security
in the United States lead to further
poverty in Cuba and prevent the changes
that are happening on the island in
February of 2018 Castro is going to
leave power and this is not the moment
for the u.s. to take a step back in
order to justify his decision Trump says
he wants to defend human rights which is
nice but don't you think is a bit
hypocritical to defend Cuba's embargo
while at the same time he hugs the
leaders of Saudi Arabia I mean human
rights not important that importantly 10
Republicans have also criticized this
course change with Cuba any policy
change that diminishes the ability of
Americans to travel freely to Cuba is
not in the best interests of the United
States or the Cuban people US Senator
Jeff Flake but now we really love to
know what you think please leave us your
comments below and feel free to answer
the survey should Donald Trump reverse
Obama's policies towards Cuba so I
really hope you did enjoyed this video
and please do hit like if you did and
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already we've got brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday and don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that are not
mine and as always I'll see you in the
next video okay you guys are playing
drama
[Music]
you